[Applause]
all the world's a stage
all the men and women merely players
but this actor has turned president
and his stage
the theatre
his audience not just parliamentarians
but a nation
and from london and all across the
country his own people too
the question for us now is to be or not
to be you all know this shakespeare
question for 13 days this question could
be asked now i can give you a definitive
answer it is definitely yes to be
a performance by president zielenski
heard in silence by the prime minister
and hundreds of mps a translation in
their headsets
i would like to remind you of the words
the united kingdom has heard before and
are important again we will not give up
and we will not lose we will fight at
sea and in the air we will continue
fighting for our land whatever the cost
invoking the eloquence of shakespeare
and the fortitude of churchill it was a
plea for help unlike any other heard in
this
i'm chamber to you boris please increase
the pressure of sanctions please
recognize russia as a terrorist state
please make sure our ukrainian skies are
safe please make sure you do what needs
to be done and what is stipulated by the
greatness of your country
in his response boris johnson promised
to deliver what's needed but no sign of
the military action the president asked
for we will employ every method that we
can diplomatic humanitarian and economic
mr speaker until vladimir putin has
failed in this disastrous venture and
ukraine is free once more
ukrainians in britain please their
president's voice as being heard here
i'm incredibly proud
that i'm ukrainian and i have a
president like that
i just realized how
how big we are
and unfortunately
it's happened in this horrible situation
but
i'm very proud of him
tightening the screw on russia will come
at a cost at home too
we either pay it now by dealing with the
threat that russia poses
and the reality that we are going to
have a serious squeeze in energy prices
they're going to rise
and that's going to knock on to food
prices and other prices too well the
alternative
is we ride it out and wait until we're
more vulnerable
westminster knows failure means tragedy
on the world stage nobody wants that
played out
sam coates sky news westminster